la question qu'on se pose maintenant
depuis vendredi tard samedi dimanche
lundi c'est pourquoi à ouagadougou
qu'est ce qui est arrivé
je pense que la meilleure personne pour
y répondre c'est notre collègue sophie
langlois que nous avons évité bonsoir
sophie soit patrice j'avais bien sûr
travailler on le sait correspondante en
afrique vous suivez quotidiennement ce
qui se passe sur ce continent d'avoir
première question pourquoi ouagadougou
maintenant on avait comme l'impression
c'est une ville épargnée un pays épargné
par le terrorisme
c'était effectivement le cas et ceux qui
connaissent la région se demandaient
pourquoi justement et la question qu'on
se posait sait comment ça se fait que
c'est pas arriver avant parce que le
petit pays du burkina faso ce petit îlot
de stabilité était entourée d'une mer
houleuse
si on regarde une carte on peut voir
qu'il ya au nord le mali et à l'est le
niger deux pays qui sont aux prises avec
des groupes d'al qaïda au maghreb
islamique et où d'autres mouvances
islamistes terroristes depuis une
dizaine une quinzaine d'années ces
pays-là subissent des attentats des
attaques des enlèvements à toutes les
semaines
normal canadien qu'est ce que veut
exactement robert fowler et louis guay
qui avaient été kidnappés au niger
détenus au mali
il avait réussi à faire oui donc al
qaïda était au tour où il y avait un
sanctuaire le burkina faso pourquoi
alors le nom de ce sanctuaire blaise
compaoré l'ancien président qui a dirigé
ce pays d'une main de fer pendant 27 ans
et le burkina faso est un petit pays une
petite économie mais blaise compaoré
était l'homme le plus puissant de
l'afrique de l'ouest
il avait la réputation de faire et
défaire des présidents il avait des
alliances partout y compris dans les cas
d'al qaïda au maghreb islamique au mali
et au niger
il avait contribué à faire libérer les
diplomates canadiens
on l'avait interview l établissement
l'aviateur roland un chef d'état
respecté avait pu établir de tels liens
aussi proche avec al qaïda au maghreb
islamique avec les autres groupes
terroristes djihadistes de la région il
nous avait clairement indiqué que
c'était quelque part son devoir
d'entretenir seigner et il avait
apparemment ce ne sera jamais confirmé
un pacte de non agression et donc quand
il l'a été chassés du pouvoir il ya un
peu plus d'un an jeu qu'on se demandait
ce n'est pas si le burkina faso allait
être attaqué mais quand ça a donc pris
une quinzaine de mois et pourquoi c'est
que pendant presque un an
les anciens proches de compaoré
l'état major de l'armée qui restait à la
tête de cette armée ont tenté de
déstabiliser le nouveau pouvoir les
autorités de transition
mais il ya quand même eu une élection il
ya un nouveau président réellement
démocratiquement élus cette fois il a
nommé son au nouveau gouvernement la
semaine dernière c'est pas un hasard si
ces attaques non au lieu de deux à peine
trois jours après la naissance de cette
nouvelle démocratie et le nouveau
président qui n'a pas donc ses liens
avec six groupes avec ce groupe et
killer ne leur doit rien les gens pieds
qui sont à la maison se pose peut-être
la question le lien avec le groupe armé
islamique el qaëda au maghreb du maghreb
islamique est en guerre c'est de la
surenchère avec le guen islamique c'est
un autre groupe alors al qaïda au
maghreb islamique est vraiment le groupe
le plus présent dans le sang donc en
afrique de l'ouest dans ces pays au sud
du sahara le mali le niger ils sont
descendus de la libye et de l'algérie
ils sont maintenant en mauritanie et oui
boko haram au nigeria par exemple à
porter allégeance à l'état islamique
mais c'est pas vraiment pour dire je
suis plus fort que vous c'est qu'on
lance une nouvelle stratégie s'attaquer
vraiment aux étrangers jusqu'ici les
entrants que les étrangers étaient les
victimes de prises d'otages
mais il n'était pas la cible comme ça a
été le cas du coup on ne me travaille en
mode et restera un des restaurants ou
des hôtels où se tiennent les
occidentaux ça a été le cas à bamako au
mali en octobre man group dirigé par ce
fameux mokhtar belmokhtar qui avait
organisé la détention et le kidnapper de
nos deux diplomates canadiens
il serait aussi derrière ces attentats
de ouagadougou et le but de cela ce
n'est pas de battre le groupe islamisme
mais bien d'envoyer des messages de
terreur de faire fuir ce qu'il considère
comme ces infidèles ces étrangers de
faire fuir les impôts
c'est ça les minières canadiennes par
exemple au burkina faso et de forcer les
musulmans modérés parce que ce sont des
musulmans modérés en afrique de l'ouest
d'adopter la charia on sait que contre
le groupe armé état islamique il y à une
coalition internationale dirigée par les
états unis il ya ces bombardements et
c'est contre al qaeda au maghreb quelles
quelles sont les forces qui se battent
contre lier les forces françaises qui
ont repoussé al qaïda au maghreb
islamique qui avait occupé la moitié du
mali donc en 2013
on peut voir une carte peut-être pour
voir à quel point pour l'heure en gros
malgré la présence donc des idées forces
françaises les forces onusiennes aussi
qu'ils sont dans la moitié nord est du
mali on peut on peut voir le pays le
mali le niger deux énormes pays
eh bien les forces françaises sont là et
des américains mais clairement ça ne
suffit pas on tue on attaque une cellule
une autre rené ailleurs ils contrôlent
ce désert cet immense territoire
ils contrôlent les trafics de
stupéfiants d'êtres humains les favoris
fugier ils se font des millions de
dollars avec ses frères ses trafics avec
les prises d'otages et quand on réussit
à les affaiblir sur un front ils
renaissent ailleurs et ça s'étend donc
oui il ya des forces qui sont là mais
clairement on l'a vu avec le burkina
faso s'est pas assez écouté les hommes
il ya un gendarme qui a participé à
l'assaut qui a dit qu'ils ont dû
attendre l'arrivée des forces spéciales
françaises pour lancer l'assaut contre
les splendides vendredi soins parce
qu'ils n'avaient même pas d'outil il
n'avait même pas de lunettes pour voir
dans le noir
il n'avait même pas d'outils pour ouvrir
des portes pare explosions
ça donne une idée ils ont besoin de
formation d'équipement ce film ça ne
s'apaisent pas là la tristesse dans la
région de québec
ce que vous nous dites mais on comprend
beaucoup beaucoup mieux c'est un jeu là
maintenant merci infiniment à la
prochain au revoir